on va essayer de refaire la même sans
regard bovin à gauche s'il te plaît
restez sourcils chez les spurs et gap
fait un effort tu sais que tu es là
parce que katia était pas dispo derrière
la bulle quelque chose de tout ce qu'on
envisage de florentin mère et moi moi ça
c'est être sensuelle on laisse tomber et
c'est plutôt d'être en fanfare alors ils
présentent beaucoup de photogénie
je pense a dit je suis droite à la pipe
on sait assez c'est quoi tes modèles
cités perdues la première avec nous s'il
te plaît plus proche de la bulle non
derrière ces murs près normale bon ben
si marquez qui a la balle taddart oui
balthazar qu'est-ce qui as-tu pourrait
sourire qu'elle critique est ce qu'il ya
c'est pas bien tapé tu es dans ta bulle
sexuellement
ça vous dérangerait d'être un petit peu
plus pauline sa part je dis ça vous
dérangerait d'être un petit peu plus
polis pu faire ça vous emmerde gérer
d'être un petit peu plus police ne fait
pas parlé aux gens comme ça c'est pas
correct
un problème ah ouais un problème il ya
un syndicaliste qui s'est perdue là